jetzt möchte ich auf ihre fragen
eingehen und diese fragen klären mit
karl lauterbach der wahrscheinlich wie
kaum jemand anders sich mit dem thema
corona in den vergangenen anderthalb
jahren befasst hat und deswegen der
richtige um diese fragen zu klären herr
lauterbach mirko köhler aus rottweil in
baden württemberg fragt gelten geimpfte
nach ablauf von sechs monaten ohne
booster als ungeimpft nein sie gelten
weiterhin als games werden irgendwann
dazu übergehen da ein ablaufdatum der
impfung zu benennen aber noch reichlich
studien lagen dafür nicht aus christian
zimmer fragt aus duisburg für immer und
ewig alle fünf monate boostern so kann
es nicht weitergehen wann kommt eine
richtige lösung werden wir uns immer
boostern lassen für unser ganzes leben
wahrscheinlich nicht also wir sehen bei
der buchung dass der impfschutz um den
faktor 10 bis 14 15 zum teil wächst und
also somit ist es sehr wahrscheinlich
dass die booster impfungen wenn man die
gemacht hat deutlich länger anhalten als
die jetzige jetzige erste und zweite
impfung aber wieviel jahre das weiß man
noch nicht also man muss immer nach den
studien gehen wir sehen aber eine so
dramatische also stark ausgeprägter
zunahme des impfschutzes dass es sein
kann dass man damit dann hinkommt wir
wissen es aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
ehrlicherweise nicht julia thiele aus
korbach in hessen fragt stimmt ist das
nur einmal geimpft die in ein
krankenhaus kommen als ungeimpft in die
statistik aufgenommen werden das stimmt
es gelten nur vollständig geimpfte aus
geimpften in der statistik das stimmt
und wie viele erst geimpfte stecken dann
in den zahlen der ungeimpften nicht
viele war das sind dann ja nur
diejenigen die sich zwischen der ersten
und der zweiten impfung infizieren und
dabei muss man bedenken dass nach der
ersten impfung zumindest zwei wochen
nach der impfung ist schon ein
ordentlicher im schutz von etwa 60
prozent da ist und wir das sind nicht
viele stefan döring aus königsberg in
sachsen fragt wie kann es sein dass ich
trotz ausreichend nachgewiesener krone
antikörper im blut nach überstandener
corona infektion zu einer impfung im
pflegeberuf gezwungen werde naja also
die antikörper sind nur ein teil der
immunität und man muss tatsächlich
sagen dass die also richtig wirklich
hart wirken der schutz erst nach der
buchung kommt da ist die außer steigt
noch einmal die schutzwirkung um den
faktor zehn bis zwanzig so viel
unterschied macht das das ist dann
natürlich ein ganz anderes schutzniveau
für die menschen die sich auf mich
verlassen wenn ich sie versorge in der
pflege michael emmaus kernig fällt bei
thüringen in thüringen fragt wie soll
ich ohne führerschein vor oder nach
meiner arbeitszeit einen zertifizierten
corona tas machen wenn die nächste test
möglichkeit 30 kilometer entfernt liegt
mein zug fährt früh um 5 uhr und ich bin
selten vor 18 uhr zu hause selbst wenn
unsere apotheke test anbieten würde was
sie nicht tut würde ich es zeitlich
nicht schaffen soll ich jetzt jeden tag
35 kilometer hin und zurück zur arbeit
laufen nein hier wäre die einzige
möglichkeit dass der test abends gemacht
wird aber
dass also das würde dann ausreichen wenn
der test abends gemacht wird und ist
noch nicht abgelaufen und man kann
diesen besonderen umständen morgens den
test vorzeigen das würde vollkommen
ausreichend es ist nicht notwendig dass
jemand morgens um 4 uhr sich testen da
ist das ist klar stefan sander fragt
wieso bekommen ungeimpfte beamtin
tarantini ihr gehalt weiter und arbeiter
nicht das hängt mit dem beamtenrecht
ganz allgemein also zusammen also der
beamte bekommt ja quasi nicht die stunde
bezahlt sondern bekommt eine also
alimentierung für ist doch unfair dass
da kann man durchaus also es gibt viele
also sagen wir ungerechtigkeiten
zwischen also beamten und nicht beamten
da wäre das eine somit ich kann dieses
gefühl gut verstehen aber der
unterschied besteht trotzdem sollte das
geändert werden das würde also das ist
eine ganz breite diskussion ob man die
beamten ob man den beamtenstatus
abschafft oder nicht das möchte ich hier
nicht diskutieren aber hier ist ein
unrecht was also ich gut nachvollziehen
kann